everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're going to be
going over a famous game from 2006
between not current Chess Champion and
Sergey K at this time he was a 16 year
old he's a grandmaster a fantastic
grandmaster at that he's played some of
the most exciting games I've seen in
recent history but I've been asked a lot
to make more videos on famous games so I
thought why not make famous games that
are related to the latest in depth
analysis that I've done on chess
openings if you've seen the last video
the knight Dorf defense this is what
that is based on so a famous game
dealing with the line that we just
talked about if you have not watched
that video I definitely recommend
watching it it does have a lot of the
ideas and the concepts that both sides
are going to be focused on so if you
don't have a lot of background it'll
make more sense in the video if you
watch that one first but we will go
ahead and get into it again this is a
non playing the black pieces and Sergey
K these 16 year old at the time playing
the white pieces so like I said before
this is the knight Dorf defense so again
be familiar with that but it starts out
with Pawnee for pawn c5 the Sicilian
Knight f3 pawn to d6 pawn d4 exchange on
d4 Knight f6 Knight c3 and then Knight
or excuse me pawn to a6 this is the
knight door of the fence right here
trying to block off this b5 Square from
an attack from not only this night here
this night here on c3 but also the
bishop coming down to b5 later on black
can look to push forward with his pawn
to b5 he does have this semi open C file
if he ever wants to bring his rook or
other pieces to attack on this semi open
C file he also can get his light square
bishop to the game on b7 once he pushes
forward with this b5 pawn from here
White's going to elect for the e3 Bishop
to e3
again if you watch the the knight or
defense video you know this is the
English attack this is the more common
line that you'll see nowadays previously
before maybe like the 1990s a lot of
times you would see Bishop to g5 this
was the main line typically nowadays you
will see Bishop to e3 still very
aggressive again we are in these
million so pretty much anything you see
is going to be very very aggressive but
this has kind of been more analyzed over
the current years as at the mainline so
from here black really has two different
options he can always bring his pawn to
e6 or he can bring his pawn to e5 Anana
Lex for the e5 which immediately is
going to push this knight back here on
d4 back here to b3 now anytime you do
see this pawn coming to e5 typically the
bishop next is going to come to e6 again
simple development move trying to get
the bishop the LightSquared bishop and
this night here on b8 out of the way so
the rook can really get involved if he
wants to come to c8 he can't always come
to b8 and start this push of b5 but
really wants to just start you know
developing his pieces he's eventually
going to get this dark squared bishop
involved into the game castle on the
Kings side typically why it's going to
look to castle on the Queen side and
then there's going to be fireworks
Black's really going to try to attack
the Queen side and why it's going to
attack the Kings side from here white
continues with pawn to f3 this kind of
serves two purposes one minor it does
protect this pawn here on e4 but more
importantly white really wants to stop
the the knight coming to g4 if you've
seen any other of the other night Dorf
defense videos or the Sicilian videos
you know this can kind of be a pain in
the rear for white as black just kind of
harasses the bishop there on e3 so
that's why the pawn comes to f3 this
also signals that white is definitely
going to be castling on the Queen side
typically if you are going to castle on
the Kings side you are either going to
start pushing this forward to open up
the F file for your rook or you're not
going to move this F pawn as at all
because this long diagonal does become a
huge weakness for you while you're
watching this video keep two things in
the back your head for the first ten
moves we're actually just doing simple
development moves in the Sicilian
defense actually up until the 23rd move
which is kind of interesting to think
about this very same game as far as the
first 20 Thurman's have been played a
year earlier in a very very important
tournament that both players afterwards
said they were familiar with they were
prepared
where they both had lines that they had
studied and prepared for in this
variation so this game actually was
going pretty fast
up to 23 when Sergey K actually deviated
from the game the previous year so just
keep that in mind
a lot of times we talk about you know
preparation going through the openings
grandmasters take it a step farther and
they actually go you know 23 moves in as
far as preparation so not to say that
you know you can't do that but but
that's pretty that's pretty crazy to me
to study that far in advance but we'll
go ahead and continue an on plays Bishop
to e7 again trying to develop his pieces
and get ready to castle on the kingside
and why it's going to play Queen to d2
again both sides simple development
moves all the way up to 10 both sides
were looking through castle and then
really start the fireworks as far as
attacking on both sides from here
black's going to castle on the kingside
white's going to castle on the Queen
side from here black's going to continue
is what we talked about he needs to get
his knight involved into the game Knight
to d7 again he could bring it tonight to
c6 if he wanted to but anon elects to
instead bring it to d7 to really not
only protect this pawn on e5 give this
outpost to c5 but also he wants to later
on either bring a rook to c8 he could
also bring a rook to c8 from the the F
file but he's really looking to attack
and harass this open the semi open C
file right here White's going to
continue with pawn to g4 if we kind of
look at it if we take a step back as far
as what both sides idea are you can see
that black has this backwards pawn here
on d6 you have the dark squared bishop
here from black is closed in it cannot
get out of this chain here if we look
from whites perspective he's Castle down
the Queen side so he really wants to
start pushing forward on the the King
side you can see his Knights are not
quite as you know dominant of the center
as possibly blacks are here but they are
still in a good position they can they
can get into the game pretty quickly but
really why it's going to start pushing
forward with the the pawns here his
pieces not so much as far as you know
attacking there's not a semi open or
open files on the kingside so White's
ideas are going to be more pushing
forward with pawns kind of a pawn attack
wall blacks really looking forward yes
he can't push forward with you know b5
but more importantly he's really looking
forward to you know opening up the semi
open file and start getting his pieces
involved into the game and really
attacked more with his pieces so just
keep in mind both of those ideas as both
sides start to progress now again if
you're familiar with the Sicilian at all
it pretty much just comes down to both
sides attacking as fast as they can
anytime you have sides castling on
opposite sides you can't just stay back
and play defense because your opponent
can just push his entire army on the
opposite side of the board up and it his
king will not be more undefended so just
keep that in mind white just is
relentlessly pushing forward and Black's
going to do the same thing on the
opposite side so the game continues
after pawn to g4 black plays pawn to b5
again pushing forward both sides White's
going to just continue marching up the
board pawn to g5 and black says you know
what you're going to push forward I'm
going to push forward see who blinks
first kind of playing a game of
cat-and-mouse here and after pawn to b4
then White's going to retreat his knight
back to e2 and black decides it's time
to bring his knight back to e8 again
both sides you can already tell pushing
pawns past that fourth and fifth rank
there's going to definitely be fireworks
both sides take the opportunity to
solidify their pawn here so White's
going to play pawn to f4 put some
solidification on this pawn on g5 I'm
not real sure if that's a word and then
pawn is going to come to a5 from black
White's going to continue up the board
pushing forward with pawn to f5 again
you definitely need to be aggressive and
black is going to play pawn to a4 from
here now why it has an interesting move
from here that he plays so I do want to
talk about it because it first glance
you may see Kevin that absolutely makes
no sense to me but instead of taking me
Bishop here on e6 white actually opts
for Knight to D
for and if you look at your like hey he
just you know he's hanging this this
night here on d4 excuse me but if you
look at it the bishop here on e6 really
has nowhere to go so he is going to get
this material back he's not actually
just hanging this night here on d4 so
keep that in mind
typically you know club players even
below
sometimes just see one or two moves in
advance but if you really look at it
there is nowhere for this bishop to go
so as far as material this is not a loss
for white black is going to take this
night here on d4 and then the Knights
going to come capture with his knight on
d4 and then the bishop here obviously he
is lost so he just accepts that and he's
going to start pushing forward again
with his pawn to b3 again he can't move
this anywhere it will die so he decides
to continue with his plan and start to
put a lot of pressure on the Queen side
as you can see black is the first side
to bring their pawn to the third-ranked
which is pretty quickly if you look at
it we're only on the 17th move and black
has already brought his pawns to the 3rd
rank black excuse me why it's going to
bring his King to be one kind of a more
secure square obviously he does want to
protect this pawn here on a2 and then
Black's going to take here on c2 and why
it's going to recapture with his knight
on c2 from here blacks going to bring
his bishop to c3 again if you look at it
you would think it's hanging but the
bishops going to fall anyway so what he
wants to do is he wants to start opening
up more files obviously he's completely
opened up the c5 which he wants he now
wants to open up this a file he does
have this rook here on a8 he can always
swing this over to c8 as we talked about
before but really if he has the C file
and the a file open it's gonna be really
hard down the road for white to you know
kind of defend both of those anytime you
can present multiple options as far as
the tax on your opponent two different
things that he has to defend it's
usually going to work out for you in the
long run so white for sure obviously he
needs to recapture
that material back on b3 and then blacks
going to play pawn to b3 attacking this
a night here on c2 wide elects to next
play Knight to a3 again if we look at
both sides kind of what their ideas are
now white really needs to protect this a
file with this C file open and this a
file opened completely for this rook to
get involved into the game it's going to
be really hard for white to hold on
unfortunately white has to play Knight
to a3 now you probably heard the saying
knight on the rim is grim you typically
don't want to have your Knights on the
side of the board especially in a very
very aggressive game which any Sicilian
game typically is you definitely don't
want to have your pieces defending space
or defending material you typically want
them to be more aggressive to be not
only defending but also attacking more
specifically attacking in this case this
Knight here on a three is going to be
more of a defender of space protecting
this a file you know for many attacks
from black he's really not going to be
involved into the action that much so
fantastic in my opinion move from black
to open up these files it really negate
the the possibility of an attack from
this Knight here on a three so we look
for black here blacks ideas are really
going to move all his pieces and really
attack on the Queen side here and white
really has to start to attack on the
King side he's you know started pushing
his pawns forward but he really needs to
start eyeing up his rooks
start pushing them down the board get
his Queen Queen involved into the game
he needs to centralize his Queen and he
really needs to use these two bishops if
he has he does have the two bishop
advantage and really start to attack
these long diagonal so just some ideas
to think about black continues with
Knight to e5 again very nice central
square from black he can hop into the
action at any time he does have some
great squares that he can get to and now
White's going to play pawn to h4 again
as we talked about white really needs to
start pushing forward and that's exactly
what he does now from here black is
going to continue with rook to a5 again
for a lot of different reasons but again
he wants to start putting more prayer
Sharan this a file so he can now if he
wants to bring his Queen over to a8 he
can start to if he wants to later on
bring his rook over to a8 putting a lot
of pressure on this a file this rook
here is protected by the Queen here on
d8 and this rook is also protecting the
night here on e5 now from here white
played Queen to c3 and this is an
important move actually a year later
this is the first deviation from the
game played Queen came to a2 which is
very different in this game the Queen
actually came to c3 now sir GK after the
game as many grandmasters evaluated this
game and asked him kind of where his
preparation went in where he felt like
he went wrong he said that this move and
the next move worthy downfall of the
game I would personally agree with him
Who am I to argue with one of the the
strongest chess minds you know out there
but we'll go ahead and get into it as
far as is why this was a problem the
next move from an on I think it's
probably one of the more brilliant moves
in the game obviously we'll get into the
most brilliant move here in a second but
it's Queen to a8 and this this again
goes on the idea that we talked about
earlier it's it's being aggressive and
still protecting your pieces so the
Queen coming to a8 does a couple things
not only does it attack this pawn here
on e4 which obviously would gain a tempo
by not only capturing but attacking the
Queen the King here on b1 but it's also
attacking and defending this rook here
on a5 so putting a very very strong
attack on this a file while still
defending this rook on a1 what this also
means is why it's going to have to use
one of his pieces since this bishop here
on the e3 is not moved it's still
blocking me pawn on e4 either the
Queen's going to have to move and
protect this somehow which would be very
difficult or he's going to have to get
his bishop involved into the game which
he ends up doing and this bishops going
to be more of a defender than he will be
an attacker later on to the game again
white really needed to get his bishops
developed attacking the long diagonals
instead he was kind of forced to sit
back and defend his pieces his pieces
were not active um and eventually he
just got crushed
so from here white played Bishop to g2
as we talked about before now the next
move was actually said to be the best
move in the tournament now if you can
think about this these are some of the
top players in the entire world and this
next move was thought to be the best
move so if you want to take a minute to
pause and see if you can find it again
really really think about the ideas that
Black has here as far as opening up
lines really attacking on the the long
files getting his major pieces involved
into the game so if you want to pause
it's a fantastic move take a minute to
look at it but the actual move that was
played was Knight to c7 and it's it's a
fantastic move and really what it does
is it gains a tempo of although it does
lose material but it really allows black
to bring all of his pieces not only
control this a file but also this C file
and really put a very very strong attack
on white what's interesting is a lot of
people ran all these engines as far as
ripka you know and all these powerful
chess engines and it took them over an
hour to see that this was actually a
winning move an onset in his preparation
he had kind of looked at it and just
kind of thought that it was the best
move obviously he probably did some deep
research but this is a fantastic find in
my opinion from here the Queen's going
to come down capture on c7 the rook is
now going to swing over to c8 again the
Queen's going to have to move so really
really gaining a time here as far as
attacking but he is losing material he's
now going to lose his bishop here on e7
fantastic idea that you can not only
give up your knight but your bishop here
for the sake of time now as we talked
about earlier black star square bishop
was locked in it was in this this chain
here so an on may have had the idea you
know what my bishop is not being used I
will gladly give that up if I can have
you know a better development
longer attack more initiative than my
opponent so sometimes if one of your
pieces or pawns you know if you can
sacrifice that if it's not being used
and it would not have been used in in
the first place you know think about an
idea of giving that material up so your
opponent's you know pieces or strategy
can kind of divert from your idea here
so black continued with Knight to c4
again putting a lot of pressure trying
to break up this Knight here on a three
so we can have this long diagonal again
putting a lot of pressure on this King
on b1 he can again move to so many
squares
he's also attacking this Bishop here on
e3 definitely definitely putting a lot
of pressure on white from here why it's
going to play pawn to g6 he is up in
material but white really starts to
understand that black has a strong
attack it's not enough to just give back
material at this point he really needs
to strike a you know strong attack here
he really doesn't have any pieces eyeing
down on the King here he has the Queen
here on e7 but the Queen can't do it by
itself so he does start to push his pawn
to g6 now black already has a great
attack going on over here but he does
need to thwart any ideas that white has
so he's going to capture with his pawn
from h7 keep in mind it would mean be
much different if he captured with his
pond from f7 he no longer has the square
h7 to retreat to so just keep that in
mind the small little things as far as
where they captured later on really
really make a big difference so anon
decides to capture with his pawn on g6
pollen recaptures and then the Knights
going to come over and capture on a3
again really trying to open up this a
file so that this strong attack can come
from black later on now white is forced
to take this material he is in check
right here so he takes and then black is
going to take with a3 now if you just
start to look at it White has literally
no defense in front of him he has a rook
here on h1 that's doing a whole lot of
nothing he has the bishop here on g2
defending the pawn on e4
which really is not doing anything he
does have the bishop on III which is not
moved from the beginning of the game he
also has the rook here on the one that
is not moved from the beginning of the
game since he castled on the Queen side
so white really needs to start try
anything to try to attack and save face
here
so from here White's going to play pawn
takes on f7 again checking his opponents
King Black's going to now come to HM and
again as we talked about this nice
little hideout and why it's going to
play Knight to f8 he senses and he
realizes that he doesn't have a much
time here anytime he does not check his
opponent he's pretty much just allowing
his opponent to check him all over the
board and potentially checkmate him so
he plays Knight to f8 and black decides
amazingly enough to sacrifice his rook
on f8 Anan said he calculated enough in
advance so that he knew that he did not
need this rook to checkmate his
opponent's king so he pretty much
thoughts that attack the Queen is forced
to come to f8 and then black unleashes
the rest of the game
a quick checkmate that Sergey K resigns
right before it finalizes but that is
rook to a1 this is all forced the King
comes to be to the word comes to a to
the King comes to c3 Queen a5 check King
over to d3 Queen b5 after the King comes
to d4 rook to a5 excuse me a for King
comes back and the Queen comes to c4
from here white resigned on the game
what striking to me is the material
disadvantage that black has he is down
to bishops and a rook here but as I
talked about so many times and so many
people allude to in in their videos as
well it's not about the pieces that you
have it's about the active pieces you
have in the fight as you can see here
actually White has one very strong
active piece in the fight
this Queen here on that faith he does
now have this bishop here on e3
attacking this one square this diagonal
here but really his rook here on D d1
his rook on h1 his Bishop here on g2 are
doing a whole lot of nothing
while Queen has you know the black Queen
and the rook here on a5 have a very very
strong attack together he does also have
a passed pawn on you know on b3 just too
much to handle from an on here and in
this case as we talked about before
sir GK was forced to resign so again we
talked about the night door of defense
it is a fantastic defense just because
it opens up so many doors you can really
be creative there's so many tactical and
sharp lines both sides really are going
to have fireworks going both sides are
going to be attacking each sides it's
really a fun way to express you know
your your chess ideas so definitely hope
you guys enjoyed this video hopefully
you're able to take some of the ideas
that anan had Sergey K may have possibly
had and use those in your own game again
if you haven't watched the neither were
defense video definitely check that out
hopefully you guys enjoyed the more
famous games videos let me know if
there's a particular one you want me to
watch and make a video on or if you just
want me to make more videos altogether
for famous games so hopefully you guys
enjoyed and I'll see you guys in the
next video thanks for watching